thank you
Thank You Stephen and thank you for the
very kind invitation so I'm going to
talk about online market with social
signals and this is going to work with a
number of my long-term collaborators
manual and Gerardo and some of my
students or former students all of all
of the people on this list are actually
spanish-speaking so every time I leave a
meeting I'm feel really bad so so the
story behind this work started with a
conversation that I had with Manuel we
said the MIT Media Lab a couple of years
ago and and I asked Manuel what is if
there is one paper in computation
computational social science that I
needed to read which one would it be
and Manuel told me to read this paper
and this is a beautiful paper by matthew
cycle nick petered out sand and Duncan
Watts looking at social market market
with social influence and it's very nice
for multiple reason and and I'll tell
you only one of them and so that's the
next thing that I'm going to do and so
we started working on this for about
three or four years after that so let me
tell you why this paper is interesting
and so so the world wide web of usually
has changed the way we are doing
shopping this is what I got from my toon
a couple of years ago when I logged in
onto it and and so obviously I Julie's
trying to you know make you buy some of
these albums and this is what they
recommend it to me no I'm not listening
to any of these stuff you can see the
song that I was listening and you know
too at the top but essentially one of
the things that I tune is doing is
choosing a couple of things that they
believe you you are very likely to buy
if you book a room in Ann Arbor in
Michigan you and you use a Orbitz for
instance you would get a list of of
potential places and one of the things
that I want to mention here is that this
list is typically ordered and the
positions obviously are very important
because humans are typically looking top
down and and and and right-to-left at
least in Western in the western part of
the world so the way you display this
product is very important obviously your
recommendation for all these products
you are very well aware of that and if I
go back to I tune again one of the
things that you see on this on this
particular on this particular
on this particular site is you see the
popularity of the various songs in this
particular case and these popularity is
actually a normalized market here and
one of the things which is interesting
here is that you see the first song this
is a u2 album a few years back and this
is the first single of the album and
what you can see is that it has a very
large popularity signal although the
song is not very good it's actually too
complex and it's not as good as some of
the top songs that you see at the top of
the at the top of the list here so so
you have all these social signals you
have all these things that you can play
with and and so what what cycle Nick
dubs and and and drunken words did was
actually trying to explain why these
social signals are actually doing
certain things to the market and their
starting point was the fact that is very
difficult to predict to predict this
this cultural market when you buy books
when you buy movies and things like this
and there are plenty of examples that
you can have of people rejecting things
that became very very popular later on
and so what they did was doing this
virtual laboratory where they were
trying to understand the
unpredictability and the efficiency and
the inequalities of these markets and to
do that they create a massive sort
computational social science experiment
using the web to study social influence
and and I'm giving you the end of the
story but you'll see many aspects of it
but what they saw is that they could
replicate all these inefficiencies these
inequalities and this unpredictability
of this market in this virtual setting
and so let me show you what they did so
what they did is is the market for songs
and not for you know famous groups so
they were unknown groups but you know
essentially what they were listing is an
order list or a grid of songs and every
one of these songs at a at this the
group the group name and then the name
of the song and they did something else
that I will mention in a moment there
the social social signal as well and
then you could actually listen to these
songs and and then afterwards you could
decide if you actually would download
this song which means that you could
keep it forever for free and so some
people did that some of the people
didn't do that and so to actually you
know understand these markets they took
all the participants and and split them
in various worlds and in every word in
every in every one of these words people
will have different social signals and
they were
so other words which you know I didn't
know by the noon by the moon where you
know you had absolutely no social
signals it's like you were alone in that
part for the place and obviously by
looking at how these words were evolving
they could you know did use what the
market was doing and so they basically
so they basically looked at these two
things so the social inference condition
and the and and and the independent
condition and one of the things that
they show is these social signals which
was essentially the number of downloads
it's like the market share I'll tell you
later on the later on that these two
things are equivalent but essentially
this was the number of of downloads of
every one of these particular songs and
they were ranking all these particular
songs by this popularity signals the
number of times every one of these songs
had been downloaded before and and and
they actually made a very good decision
there because popularity is probably the
best social signals there were a lot of
studies afterward trying to find out if
recommendations were better'n or not but
most of the time this is seen as the
better social signals that you can sent
in in these social markets so so these
are some of the results that Duncan
summarized about ten years after they
did this and one of the things that he
said is that the best songs actually
never do very badly they may do very
well but any result is possible and the
other things that they were say that
Duncan summarized is that the dynamics
can be manipulated but not easily so
these markets are very unpredictable
essentially and so when Manuel should
show that to me my first reaction was
that what if we optimized because you
know I'm an optimizer by training so I
said what if we optimize this market all
the time what would be the result and
which would that change the
predictability the efficiency and so on
because you have a lot of things that we
can optimize obviously you can decide
what you show you how you show it what
is the order in which you saw these
things you can choose the social signals
if you use it or if you don't use it and
obviously you have to model the the
utilities and so what we try to do is to
try to see if we can optimize this
market or listicle e using all these
things and see what would be the result
and that's what we started to do so let
me formalize a little bit the problem so
what we have this is this online market
participants are coming and they have
the ability to sample a product so they
can listen to the song or they can read
some extra support of a book and then
once they've done that they can decide
if they buy the product or not
and so the popularity signals will
influence only the sampling step they
will decide what they actually listening
to it doesn't impact the quality of the
product obviously and then the next
participant comes and you have to decide
you know which product you show and in
which order and which social signals you
show and you repeat that for for a long
time and so Manuel you know who I
mentioned at the beginning actually work
with some of the people in the Media Lab
to try to formalize this so they reverse
engineer all the experiment and that was
and his colleagues did and so they could
find out what the visibility parameters
were the quality of the products and the
appeal of the products and they
formalized that is a generalized
multinomial logit and so so what you see
on the screen there is the probability
for trying sampling product is step a
step K and it depends on the visibility
of the product where the product is
positioned it also depends on the appeal
of the product is this a product that
appeals to you or not and then the
social signal here
which is the number of purchases that
have happened in the past and then you
normalize this for having a probability
distribution and so and so this is this
is what they did and obviously what we
are interested in is maximizing the
expected number of products that you're
going to download and this is
essentially the problem you know
multiplying the probability of sampling
a product by the quality of the product
and so we want to do that over you know
you know over time essentially and
mostly the degree of freedom that we
have here is what social signals we
choose and and also in which order you
display this product that's where the
visibility comes in no abuse yes sir
visibility signal is this part there
this this guy here and this is where you
position the product in the list if you
put something on top it's much higher in
the visibility is higher so the
probability of actually sampling it is
actually higher I thought you would ask
another question which is what is the
quality because that seems to be very
subjective but the quality here we are
using an insight from that paper as well
which is the fact that the only thing
that we are really interested here is
the probability of actually downloading
a product or purchasing a product once
you have sampled it so that's what we
mean by quality here it's a quality of a
particular point in time that's the
intrinsic probability of downloading the
product or buying the product if you are
actually sampling
and you can estimate this very nicely
using a Bernoulli sampling and this is
actually very nice because the you know
you learn the best you know the best
product the product with a higher
quality of the lower quality I learn
very fast because the variance depends
on the quality is so so so then we
started optimizing and the first thing
which is very nice is that if you try to
find the best permutation for this
product you can do that in strongly
polynomial time using a reduction to a
linear fractional assignment problems
and we can actually do better in
practice in experimentally so you can
solve these things for very large number
of products very very efficiency you can
do that in real time which is nice but
this is just optimizing at every one of
the step but every one of the steps you
decide which is the best you know
ranking of the products you know
presentation of the product that you can
have and so that's a good news and when
you look at what does this happen in
practice this is based on the on the
data from the music lab you see two
things first optimizing just optimizing
with no shirts for signals give you
significant benefits so that's the V
just optimizing the visibility so what
you see here is the optimization
approach this is the popular it is
signal this is not using anything like a
random ordering and then the second
things that you see and this is on the
right of the picture is the influence of
social is a benefits of social influence
and these two things are cumulative so
if you use both optimization and the
social signal you get a much better
market efficiency that if you don't and
so the other fix that you can see is the
predictability of the market so this is
essentially what Duncan Watts and its
colleagues has said so this is
essentially what you see here is the
quality of the products on the on the
x-axis every one of these bar is a
product this is the number of purchases
or downloads and this is repeated over a
large number of experiments so you can
see here that this best product can do
very well or can do so-so or everything
in between is possible that's what you
know they said so it's a very
unpredictable market if you use the
popularity ranking if you use the
optimization approach what is very nice
is that this market becomes highly
predictable so the best product here is
a very large share of the of the market
that does particular point I'll come to
you the other products have less and you
can see that the social signals is
giving the the best product of a very
big boost yes
by the quality which you're plotting on
the top left yeah
the quality is estimated from the data
yeah yeah yeah so you can you can just
you can just let people let people play
it you can let the market go and every
time some of these samples that
particular product you can estimate the
probability that this person will don't
know the product and so you get an
estimation of the quarter probability of
downloading so this is order so this so
every one of the bar here is a product
and this is the number of time that the
product is is actually download it'll
purchase this over a large number of
experiment let's say 200 experiments so
you see that this product once has been
non loaded like you know 300 times and
once like 250 times in another
experiment okay and this product was
downloaded about six thousand times in
one experiment in another one it was
like two hundred times and those confuse
me no to the left because this this
product was not loaded about the
thousand time in one if the experiment
and this and and the next thing was like
one left
yes to dot downloaded very often yes I
mean I don't know so this is there is
some unpredictability here right so so
this is this is what they say it is very
unlikely to be predictable right and
it's unpredictable you don't see that
when you are actually optimizing okay so
you don't see that this is this is nice
okay so this is optimization is nice
right okay the other one is popularity
ranking it really depends on the initial
condition right so this product somehow
you know in some for some reason in this
experiment that's what happened okay so
so so obviously we were like you know
Florian yesterday said okay so we have
all these things behaving nicely can we
prove something about it except that
this is much simpler than what Florian
is doing but we knew nothing about this
so we started simplifying things such
that we can prove things and so the
first thing that we did was using this
quality ranking you take all the
products and you rank them by quality
and you present them that way so the
best product of the best visibility and
so on
so this is this is not dynamic at all
you just have a static ranking and very
interestingly the static ranking order
by quality behaved almost as well and
sometimes better than the optimization
approach and it's dominated sometimes at
the beginning but then they tend to
converse to the same thing and so that
was very interesting for us and when you
look at the predictability this is what
you see again so you can see that that
the quality of ranking once again is
even more predictable than the
optimisation approach so we were like
wow this is interesting
so so then we started proving things and
the first thing that you can do is to
show that if you use this quality
ranking you can actually prove that the
number of download is is going to be
increasing monotonically over time and
so in expectation every time you
maximize the number of product the
number of expected products that you can
download at every step I mean it's a
fraction of a product but you you are
doing you are doing better and so this
is this was interesting and and most of
these crews rely on the expected number
of downloads and the relationship
between the quality of the products and
this this is very traditional in these
in these assortment problems and the
next thing that you can prove is that
the market is actually going to a
monopoly for the best product
asymptotically and and I'll tell you a
little bit what we prove this but the
intuition here is that you can model
Munich and you can model that like
generalize Polya earn with reinforcement
so you extract a product and then you
put you know these products in a you
know a number of times this product
inside inside the bins as well and I'll
show you a little bit more detail later
on so in a sense when you use the
quality ranking we converge to a
monopoly in at the limit with for the
best product so it's not highly
predictable and socially influence is
always good in expectations so and it's
it is optimal asymptotically and what I
like is that it's not only good for the
market the market you know this is
optimal for the market but it's also
very good for the customers because they
are driven to the best product in a
sense the product that is the best
quality and so you can prove the same
thing for the optimization approach it
also goes to a monopoly the limit on the
best product and you can you can
generalize that to a solvent problem
using the algorithm that some of the
algorithm that David and and part have
used in the past so as a basic
optimization approach so so you so
essentially all these things are nice ok
so let me let me tell you a little bit
let's try to make this a little bit more
realistic now and one of the things that
people always complain is that yeah but
you assume that all the customers are
kind of a mill genius what happens if
there are different class of users that
they have different kinds of appeal and
different kind of utilities for every
one of the product and so this is you
can generalize this and know essentially
what is happening is that the quality
appeal of the product and the quality of
the product is going to depend on on the
classes of users and so you can ask
exactly the same question what is that
what do you present to the customer son
and its other popular it is a signal
beneficial and there you have bad news
if you try to optimize this is np-hard
under curing reduction so it's very
difficult to do and it's actually very
difficult in practice at least on the
instances that we looked at so we can't
really optimize this globally so what we
can do is we can say hey let's average
the quality of the product and let's
reason about this and the proof on a
nasty but essentially what you can do is
that you will will always converge to
the product which is this average
quality but unfortunately showing a
social signal for this particular for
this particular product can can actually
deteriorate the quality by a factor of K
where K is the number of classes of
customers so it's actually pretty bad it
can be pretty bad but there are good
news so what you can do is you can say
hey if I segment the market then things
are very different and and many of the
websites that you find there typically
allow you to actually view the reviews
by different categories if you are
single or if you are a couple or if you
have children and so on and so I do they
learn these things so that you can tell
them the information but if you know the
type of a participant what you can do is
exactly do what we did for the want
diamo genius case and and orient the
people to the different the world they
belong to the category they belong to
and then you can use the quality of
ranking or the optimization approach to
do that and when you do that you can
show that you can improve the
performance by a factor of K that's in
theory and this bount is tied and we can
reproduce it on experiment this is one
of the experiment and what you can see
there is that social influence on the on
the average quality can be really bad
and we can show so that social influence
can bring very significant benefits when
you do this this is more on and
represent benefits in a sense
so so in a sense even if you do if you
do market segmentation you you the
market is predictable is optimal as
fantastically and you benefit from the
social signals now I presented this to a
conference in social science
computational social science and people
were extremely uncomfortable with these
results because they say yes you had the
rest predictability you address the
efficiency of the market but you
increase inequality substantially and
they asked us if we could actually
mitigate that the fact that you
introduced substantial inequalities
between the products and so what we
started looking at is can you change the
social signals to have a notion of
fairness inside the market and so what
I'm going to show you I'm going to show
you the results here but the result in
terms of market share which is really
equivalent to the number of downloads
and so so what I'm going to do is
exactly the same thing the visibility is
there but then you have a function now
which depends on on the market share
like in you know I tune and the kind of
social signals that I'm going to look at
is a is a polynomial of the market share
and so what we did so far is using R
equal 1 but I want to look at R equal
you know smaller equal to 1 obviously
greater than zero and so this is all the
market share evolves and this is gonna
give you an idea of how we prove some of
these things so this is the market share
in step k plus 1 in terms of the market
share at time scale one of the things
that you see there is this random vector
which denotes the product which is
downloaded in this discrete product the
product with the product which is
downloaded at a particular point in time
and then if you start playing with this
you can introduce the expectation of
downloading a particular product given
the current market share and once you do
this you get this beautiful algorithm
you get this beautiful formulation here
which probably every one of you knows
which are this beautiful Robin Robins
Monro algorithm I knew nothing about
this but essentially what you have is
that F is continuously differentiable
here the gamma k plus 1 there is
essentially converging to 0 and and some
and if you sum all these all these
things that they sum to infinity and
then the the UK plus 1 is kind of the
noise and that noise converges to 0 and
once you have this thing you can prove
you can use this beautiful book by
Kirchner and yang if I remember
correctly and
and the interesting story about this is
that this person was actually sitting
next to me for 22 years and I never
talked to him I mean a kind of a quarter
of a mile and then I discovered this
fantastic book afterwards but
essentially if you want to know about
this Robbins monitor algorithm you read
this book and you know everything and so
one of the things that you can do is use
this approximate this particular
discrete you know process stochastic
process with another ordinary
differential equations and you can study
the continuous the continuous the
properties of this continuous OD E and
so essentially what you do is you have
the suit so what you see here is a
solution of the OD e you know it's
approximate essentially the market the
discrete the discrete process here and
so the only thing that you need to do is
study this equilibria and then prove
some convergence result and one of the
things that you can show is that if the
the social signal now is smaller than R
it's more than one then all the
equilibria are going to be these
monopolies plus an internal equilibria
and inside the simplex which really
depends on the quality of the product
and what you do there is you assign or
share the market share is becoming
proportional to the quality of the
product but there is no monopoly so this
is what it looks like and this is kind
of nice because this converges very
quickly in the market so the market come
you know converge very quickly to this
equilibrium and the best product is
always you know at the top and then you
know that all the other products depends
on the quality and and so whatever the
appeal of the product at the beginning
they converge to this nice market here
so you can prove this that actually if
you start with nonzero market here for
every one of the product you're going to
converge to this inner equilibrium and
the way you do that is basically by
induction because if you remove one
product and you put it aside the rest is
still or Robbins Munroe algorithm so you
can prove that by induction and the
other things that you need is
essentially the the the the key property
of the continuous dynamics so this R is
smaller than one so this is actually
converging two to zero and therefore
these two things are actually showing
you that this is the market share
equilibrium that I've shown you before
and so this is nice as well so the
market is predictable in this particular
case it has no monopoly so the
computational social scientists are much
much happier
and then it has some notion of fairness
because the product of higher quality
will have a larger market here which is
something which is desirable and then
the market converts to this nice
equilibrium if the appeal if the appeals
and the quality of strictly positive
when you start and so the conversion
doesn't depend on the appeal it doesn't
depend on the initial condition you will
always converge to this nice equilibrium
and and the conversion seems to be
extremely fast if you look at the social
signals which is greater than 1 then
exactly the same equations are still
true but know these terms converge to
infinity because R is greater than 1 and
T is increasing and therefore the
analysis of this is more is different
and essentially what you have is that
all these all these market share except
one are going to converge to 0 and so
you go to a you go to essentially
monopolist in general the inner
equilibrium is still there it's still a
property is still in equilibrium but
it's unstable you can show that
essentially one of the eigen value of
the Jacobian of the of the function f is
is is positive and so the so what what
this means here is that the conversions
really depends on the initial appeals
and you don't know which monopoly you're
going to get to so if you look at the
results this is what you see once again
you can see that when you optimize I use
the quality ranking in this particular
case you are better than the popularity
ranking and the more are the more R
grows the more the difference between
the popularity ranking and the quality
ranking is increasing and also what you
see here is the is the predictability
results and once again as long as R is
smaller than 1 everything is predictable
when it gets up you know what is get
greater than 1 and this is 2 even when
you use the quality ranking you
introduce unpredictability inside the
market and the popularity ranking is
completely unpredictable as as what's
and his colleagues have actually shown
so let me conclude so so we started with
this paper which was very interesting
because it was basically showing you on
a you know in a virtual setting and
analyzing and showing you that that if
you do the natural thing which is this
popularity ranking you get inefficiency
and predictability and increase
inequality in this market
and I want to actually come back to some
of the things that what sets in when you
summarize the results that the best
songs never do terribly and the worst
songs never do very
but any other resource is possible and
that the dynamics cannot be manipulate
is 'le this is obviously completely true
in what they have been doing and this
has been replicated by many people so
they also actually look at why this is
the case and I'm not a social scientist
so I can't choose between these
arguments but one of the figures that
they were saying is that inequality is
and unpredictability are in a run to the
market essentially and and and it's very
difficult to understand where the market
is going if you don't know that if you
know only the end individual preferences
but this is only true you know if you do
exactly what they do if you actually do
other things like you know the
optimization approach for the quality
ranking then it's completely predictable
the best song is always going to do the
better you know do do the best if are
equal one and and the best songs are
always going to do better if if the
social signal is less than one and the
dynamic is can be easily manipulated in
a sense you use optimization or the
quality ranking so it really it really
depends of what you are doing
algorithmically when you present the the
market to the users and social influence
is always beneficial if R is equal to
one it's true empirically when R is is
is between zero and one but it's we are
you know we have counter example showing
that it's not always true and the market
is obviously fully predictable as long
as R is small or equal to one so in a
sense if you look at what they did in
the music lab they did the natural thing
they ranked by popularity ranking they
ranked by popularity which is what you
know you know people would try first but
the key point is that popularity is very
different from quality and what mostly
we are doing when you are optimizing or
using these quality ranking we are
basically aligning popularity and
quality and making sure that the
popularity is actually reflecting
quality so there are many open issues so
the first one is that social influence
is not always beneficial when R is more
than one we have Contour example showing
that it can actually be detrimental but
typically this is when the appeal and
the quality are already online then you
basically the best product is not as
good as as it should have been it get a
smaller market share but the nice point
here is in this particular case is that
you can actually test before because we
know the equilibrium so you can test
what is the expected downloads at the
equilibrium and if whether you use
social influence or not and so you can
decide what to do beforehand
optimality we don't know what is the
optimal ranking the quality ranking is
not is not optimal actually it's very
interesting so we have a contour example
where you put the best product on top
but the second product is the worst one
so that you maximize the share of the of
the best product so we don't know what
the optimal ranking is and obviously we
need more complex model for actually
when the the the participants come from
different different utilities and so on
we validate this experimentally using
also large scale you know experiment but
need Momo needs to be danced there
because we could replicate some of the
result but not all of them this these
things take a huge amount of time and
resources so that's what I wanted to
tell you and I'll be happy to I'll be
happy to take any questions if you have
some so thank you very much
[Applause]
so what we do is we do this sampling
approach so we basically sample at the
beginning and we can estimate it very
quickly I could show you conversion
results very quickly we can actually
estimate the quality of the of the
various products so we can do that
relatively easy in this particular
setting whether this is three note
setting you know I don't know but in
this particular setting we can choose
two sampling and determine the quality
of the products yes Steve yeah so if we
can actually find out in which bubble
they live in then we can optimize for
that particular bubble I'm not saying
this is good right so but we can
optimize for that bubble and then we are
optimal with respect to that bubble
another thing this is good but this is
what you can do from an algorithmic
standpoint so I think if we can find out
what you know it will kind of find out
who people are similar with freezer pack
today's taste quality and appeal then we
can optimize with respect to that and
that's the results that I've shown you
yeah so we can learn that we can this is
one of the things that is nice you can
combine that with machine learning to
know you know what are the Preferences
of a group of people and and things like
this
thank you
[Applause]